also in gewisser weise kann ich das auch
nachvollziehen meine hohen schuhe trage
ich eher selten
haywood ihres glaubens willkommen beim
ein video und zwar hab ich also vor ein
oder zwei wochen ist ihr daraus gemacht
wobei mädchen immer lügen oder wobei
mädchen lügen und das ist echt mega gut
bei euch angekommen ich glaube das hat
schon über 250.000 klicks oder auch
schon fast 20.000 wächst keine ahnung
auf jeden fall hat mich das mega gefreut
und ihr habt doch wirklich noch ganz
viele weitere dinge wobei mädchen oder
wo war er als mädchen liegt in den
kommentar geschrieben
die gehen wir heute also ein bisschen
durch wieder gleiches prinzip wie
letztes mal ich wünsche euch viel spaß
auch soja und wobei jungs leben kommt
natürlich auch dann noch ein zweiter
teil ich glaub das ist auch sehr
interessant und da kann ich dann auch
aus meinen erfahrungen sprechen ich will
gar nicht lange lagern wir fangen direkt
an und los gehts ja leute tage schreibt
hallo alex wie ich finde mal einen
freund und wir haben uns immer gute
nacht und herzt herz herz geschrieben
das heißt gerade wirklich der kommentar
sarah freut mich sehr für dich aber das
passt überhaupt nicht zum thema
management gut machen wir weiter mit dem
kommentar von alice und sie sagt frauen
lügen sich selber immer an wenn sie sich
hohe schuhe kaufen nein mann ich werde
die so oft tragen die sind locker bequem
nach drei jahren hatte ich die mal
gekauft ja das kann ich auf jeden fall
hinein nicht nachvollziehen aber ich
kann es auf jeden fall verstehen also
ich habe jetzt keine runden schule habe
ich also ich weiß nicht ob das bei allen
mädchen jetzt der fall ist aber ich kann
wirklich ziemlich gut vorstellen wenn
man halt gern mal hohe schuhe trägt ich
als junge habe jetzt nicht so das
problem wenn ich mir schuhe kaufe habe
ich aber auch auf das problem dass ich
mir nach zwei wochen denke die sind
scheiße also in gewisser weise kann ich
das auch nachvollziehen meine hohen
schuhe trage ich eher selten okay leute
nächst lüge mädchen lügen wenn sie ein
romantisches status bei whatsapp haben
und gefragt werden ob ihnen das bezogen
ist die antwort ist dann meistens so was
sie auf gar niemanden
das ist bloss einen songtext oder ich
fand den spruch so cool aber da ist kein
typ und meistens glauben wir uns dabei
selbst nicht ja ich denke mal dass es
überall so egal es gibt auch so viele
leute die schreiben bei snapshot
übrigens nächste woche kommt noch
richtig geiles snap chat video mit einem
coolen gas ist aber jetzt auch egal auf
jeden fall gibt es ja auch bei snapshot
das schreiben so welche so richtig
romantische texte und manchmal weißt du
als junger also jetzt gerade zum
beispiel beim jetzt nicht so aber es
gibt so wirklich da weißt du genau das
auf dich bezogen ist ich play walter den
spaß aber ihr kennt das bestimmt jungs
machen das ja auch manchmal so ich jetzt
eigentlich nicht aber es gibt auch jungs
die das machen gut ist jetzt nicht so
meins aber jedem dh
ihr seid als mädchen auch nicht alleine
das hat sich jetzt geräumt weil ich der
coolsten und denke ich bin im kilt
lassen ist okay wir machen weiter das
kenne ich das kenne ich echt eda
schreibt mädchen lügen wenn du fragst
ist das jetzt wieder neue zum beispiel
eine tasche und sie sagt dann ist schon
voll alt ich denke manchmal selber ob
ich schon wenn so alsheimer assistiert
das ist echt so du siehst was das hat er
diese person oder das mädchen noch nie
an und du fragst dich oh ist das neue
solution for one nine hast du nicht du
hast dich nein nein das kann ich richtig
verstehen da verstehe ich jetzt auch
nicht warum man nicht einfach sagt ja
das ist neu doch cool man was neues hat
aber gut ich muss nicht alles verstehen
will ich auch gar nicht okay leute die
lorenz gehe oder so schreibt das habe
ich gerade schon durch gelesene ich
wette ich wette das stimmt mädchen lügen
wenn sie sagen nein ich sag's keinem
anderen versprochen
sie sagen es wirklich kaum außer der
besten freundin ich sage meiner besten
freundin jede kleinigkeit außerdem darf
sie immer einmal ein handy und ich weiß
was wahr weiß sie auch ja das freut mich
sehr für dich dass deine beste freundin
dein passwort weiß ich habe auch er
mitführte viel spaß obwohl du kannst es
mir eigentlich mal zukommen lassen meine
e-mail-adresse schild in der
beschreibung dann komme ich mal nachts
besuchen claudia ein handy uns deutlich
ist auch egal ihr müsst meine vorlieben
gar nicht unbedingt erfahren kommen wir
auf jeden fall zurück zum thema und zwar
kann ich da sagen das finde ich wirklich
gut ich meine wenn man irgendwann sagt
so yao sagt was bitte kein dann kann man
oft davon ausgehen dass diese person ist
vielen anderen leuten sagt habe ich auch
schon auf mit erfahrung gemacht ist
leider so aber ich find's gut dass ihr
als mädchen das wirklich eine ihrer
besten freundin erzählt wobei das
wahrscheinlich auch nicht bei allen der
fall ist ihr könnt ja meine kommentare
schreiben ist das oder ist das nicht
seid ehrlich weil denkt nicht dass eure
freunde jetzt den kommentar unter meinem
video lesen ja solange es bei der besten
freundin bleibt ist das finde ich okay
außer die beste freundin ist halt in
wirklichkeit nicht eure beste freundin
und ihr seid dann ihr wisst was ich
meine
ok leute kommen wir zur letzten lüge die
ariola schreibt mädchen lügen manchmal
wenn sie auf in salon gehen und einen
kommentar unter einem bild schreiben zum
beispiel hübsche das machen sie nur weil
sie wollen dass diese person auch ohne
ihren bildern so was schreibt ist
einfach so hätte hätte ich jetzt erstmal
nein zu gesagt ich weiß ihr könnt doch
wieder einen kommentar schreiben
stimmt das oder stimmt das nicht aber
ich meine wenn man eine freundin hat und
schreibt man da gerne immer hübsche
drunter ach so ja herr das macht dann
noch ein paar aus dem grund um seiner
freundin der freude zu machen oder nicht
okay ich würde sagen das ist so 50%
wahrheit 50 prozent nicht können wir uns
darauf einigen
wenn nicht dann schreibt in die
kommentare dann lassen daumen nach unten
da oder schreibt ich bin scheiße und
hässlich und egal leute das war's mit
diesem video wenn es euch gefallen hat
dass jetzt noch nach oben da vielleicht
kommen wir auch noch eine dritte folge
machen dann schreibt weitere dinge wobei
mädchen lügen unten in die kommentare
wir sehen uns dann am nächsten dienstag
oder mittwoch wieder nächste woche kommt
leider nur ein video gleich ziemlich
viel stress hat also in der woche kommt
ein video am dienstag oder mittwoch und
am sonntag ganz normal das haupt video
und ich würde sagen ich wünsche euch
eine schöne woche wir sehen uns nur drei
leute in sam server als angewendet die
unbedingt weiter mit meinem letzten
video